Saqueos, manifestaciones, bloqueos y
enfrentamientos. En inicios de año ha
sido un explosivo para México que han
producido muertes y las detenciones se
cuentan por cientos. Pero, ¿qué ha
provocado semejante ola de violencia?
Los que nos estáis viendo desde México
lo sabéis bien ha sido lo que se conoce
como el "gasolinazo". Y para hablarnos de
ello vamos a contar con la colaboración
de nuestro buen amigo Antonio Tadeo,
periodista mexicano. Que tal amigos de
VisualPolitik. Así es en esa ocasión hablaremos del
gasolinazo en México. Para todos
aquellos que queráis seguir la actualidad
de México
podéis ver los informativos de
Antonio desde la página de Facebook DI Tv Live.
El gobierno ha decretado para el 2017 un
incremento récord en el precio de la
gasolina de casi el 20 por ciento. El pueblo de méxico está furioso no
sólo por la subida de los carburantes
sino también por la sensación de que
las élites política les están
engañando. Hechos violentos ocurrieron
en Baja California, como ejemplo de ello
en donde civiles se enfrentaron con
elementos de la policía federal que
trataron de desalojar un bloqueo en las
instalaciones de la petrolera mexicana
PEMEX. En los saqueos hubo de todo, desde
golpes hasta balazos sin dejar de lado
la histeria colectiva de la población
quienes realizaron guardias vecinales
enfundando palos, piedras machetes y 'las
armas de fuego para defender sus barrios.
En este vídeo vamos a explicar qué
ha ocurrido y lo vamos a hacer por dos
motivos: primero porque sin lugar a dudas
es la noticia hispana más importante con
la que comienza 2017 y segundo porque nos
lo habéis perdido ha sido impresionante
una locura. En los últimos días nos
habéis enviado cientos, probablemente miles
de mensajes y comentarios pidiéndonos
que hablemos de ello. Así que, vamos allá. a día
EL GASOLINAZO -
Lo primero que tenemos que
tener en cuenta es que el sector del
petróleo en México no es un mercado
libre. Sí, es cierto, como veremos hay en
marcha una reforma para abrir la
competencia pero de momento PEMEX de la
petrolera estatal mantiene el monopolio
y por tanto el gobierno sigue tomando
todas las grandes decisiones.  honda
¿Y cuál ha sido su última gran decisión?
Pues incrementar en 2017
el precio de la gasolina en hasta un 20
por ciento, el mayor incremento de los
últimos 20 años. ¡Qué se dice pronto! Y claro esto ha sido un golpe durísimo
para muchas familias,
un bombazo para su presupuesto. Pero, ¿por
qué se ha tomado una medida tan
impopular? En todas esas manifestaciones
existe un común denominador, un culpable
un villano favorito como el de la
película,  su nombre Enrique Peña Nieto,
de quien dicen que el término de
soberanía nacional y conflicto de
intereses no tiene significado alguno en
su administración.
El presidente de
México, Enrique Peña Nieto y su
gobierno afirman que esa subida se debe
exclusivamente a que al precio
internacional del petróleo y de la gasolina
han subido mucho.
"¿Por  qué subió entonces
el precio de la gasolina? Porque en el
último año en todo el mundo
el precio del petróleo aumentó cerca
de 60 por ciento".
Así que la pregunta que tenemos que
hacernos, ¿es esto verdad? Pues a tenor de
los datos sí lo es:  en 2016 el precio del barril de petróleo west texas intermediate, que
podemos considerar una referencia para
México, subió aproximadamente en un 50
por ciento.
Y claro como es evidente, si el petróleo
sube la gasolina también lo hace.
Vamos a ver qué ha ocurrido en Estados
Unidos que es el principal suministrador
de gasolina para México. Sí, habéis
escuchado bien, México es una
potencia petrolera pero tiene que importar
más del 60 por ciento de la gasolina
que consume y cada vez más. Es decir
en métodos más llanos, México vende las
naranjas al vecino de al lado y al mismo
vecino le compra jugo de naranja pero
mucho más caro.
Eso es lo que pasa con la gasolina en
este país. A los gobiernos mexicanos les
ha importado un pimiento o sea nada
eso  de desarrollar una industria
energética independiente y competitiva.
El caso es que éste es el gráfico de
cómo ha evolucionado durante 2016
el precio por galón de la gasolina
normal en Estados Unidos, podemos ver
que el precio ha subido algo más del 20
por ciento.
Así que aparentemente Enrique Peña
Nieto estaría en lo cierto. Pero esperad un
momento amigos porque hay algo más.
Y en este caso me dirijo al excelentísimo
presidente Don Enrique Peña Nieto.
Señor presidente usted no nos está
diciendo toda la verdad,
el pueblo mexicano no está indignado
sólo porque la gasolina haya subido un
20%, ésta señor ha sido la gota que ha
colmado el vaso.
Señor presidente durante su mandato la
gasolina ha subido casi un 50% y es más
cara que en los mismísimos Estados
Unidos algo no está funcionando.
La responsabilidad de Peña Nieto. Cuando
Peña Nieto llegó al poder
se encontró con que la gasolina en México
era subsidiada por el estado.
Es verdad que el anterior presidente
Felipe Calderón ya había reducido
sustancialmente el subsidio pero éste
continuaba existiendo. Y la verdad
subvencionar la gasolina es una de las
peores cosas que pueden hacer los
gobiernos.
El estado gasta muchísimo dinero, la
subvención va a parar mayormente a las
personas con más recursos y encima se
incentivan modelos económicos y
hábitos de consumo que gastan
muchísima gasolina. Un buen ejemplo son
los coches que utiliza la gente en México, gran parte son coches usados
importados desde Estados Unidos.
Estos coches tienen unos motores
enormes que consumen muchísima gasolina. Claro, cuando la gasolina es muy barata a
nadie le importa ahorrar pero ahora...   instalaciones de pemex
Esto explica que México prácticamente
que me gasolina. Su consumo per cápita
es superior al de países como
España, Alemania, Francia o por ejemplo
más del doble que el de Brasil. Ahí es nada.
Y os preguntaréis:
preguntaréis entonces, ¿por qué se
mencionan los combustibles? Pues casi
siempre para comprar votos.
El caso es que Don Enrique Peña Nieto
terminó con esta política en 2014, algo
que en principio parece bueno, ¿verdad? Pues el problema es que por aquel
entonces los ingresos del gobierno por
la exportación de petróleo estaban
cayendo montón y a peña nieto no se le
ocurrió nada mejor que compensarlo con
más impuestos, muchos más impuestos.
En concreto en las gasolinas de México
casi el 40 por ciento del precio de hoy
son impuestos.
Cuando el petróleo estaba por los suelos, pues
éstas impuestos parecían pesar menos
menos pero cuando el petróleo sube...
Está muy bien haber eliminado las
subvenciones pero fijar de forma tan
repentina unos impuestos tan altos ha
supuesto un castigo enorme para las
familias mexicanas sobre todo cuando
encima están perdiendo tanto poder
adquisitivo por la mala situación
económica.
El poder adquisitivo cae un 11 por
ciento en los últimos cuatro años"
Así que, señor presidente, cuando le
quiera contar al pueblo lo que ha
ocurrido por favor
cuéntele todo. Hoy en día Enrique Peña
Nieto registra el nivel de popularidad
más baja de un presidente desde que en
México se registra la popularidad de un
mandatario
estos desde 1995. Y ojo la más baja en
la historia de credibilidad en la clase
política mexicana.
Ahora bien muchos de los críticos, la
mayoría de ellos tal vez, tampoco se
salvan.
La reforma energética. En 2013 el
presidente Peña Nieto puso en marcha la
que era una de sus mayores promesas
electorales: la reforma energética, que
entre otros aspectos contemplaba
liberalizar el sector del petróleo. Es
decir, permitir que nuevas empresas
compitan con PEMEX.
Hoy muchas denuncian que esta reforma es
la culpable del gasolinazo, lo que
sencillamente como hemos visto no es
cierto.
Fijaros amigos de VisualPolitik,
México es una potencia petrolera
pero importa la mayor parte de la gasolina
que consume. Además como no se ha
invertido lo suficiente, a pesar de
contar con grandes yacimientos, cada vez
produce menos petróleo y por si fuera
poco PEMEX, la compañía estatal de
petróleos propiedad el gobierno que ha
operado en régimen de monopolio, está
en quiebra. Sólo conocemos un caso igual de
desastroso el de PDVSA en Venezuela.
Una de sus primeras políticas fue el
llamado sistema de democratización del
empleo que implementó en la empresa
PDVSA que es la compañía estatal de
Venezuela.
Gran parte del problema ha sido que
PEMEX en vez de utilizar los recursos
generados para invertir y mejorar sus
capacidades ha sido literalmente saqueada
por los diferentes gobiernos para
financiar gasto corriente. Y encima
ha sido un pozo de corrupción y
clientelismo.
Vamos que no se puede continuar así y
aún hay más: en los últimos tiempos
el tipo de cambio del peso mexicano
frente al dólar estadounidense está
sufriendo muchísimo, lo que por sí
mismo también es una mala noticia para
el mercado de combustibles que como
hemos visto depende en gran medida de
las importaciones desde Estados Unidos. "Este disparo que ha tenido la moneda
mexicana hasta estos niveles de depreciación,
en lo que va del año del 13,71%
Y aquí una mala noticia
amigos: los impuestos, la mala situación
financiera del gobierno mexicano, el
desastre de PEMEX y el tipo de cambio
sólo auguran precios de la gasolina
más elevados aún. Así que amigos
mexicanos vigilad bien vuestra cartera.
Por cierto a todos los amigos que nos
estáis viendo desde México,
queremos enviaros un mensaje especial
desde VisualPolitik. Donald Trump ha insultado
gravemente a México e incluso ha
tratado de humillar a vuestro pueblo con
su amenaza de obligarlos a pagar su muro
de la vergüenza.
Sin embargo ni lo ha conseguido ni lo
va a conseguir. Queremos que sepáis que contáis
con toda nuestra solidaridad, apoyo y
cariño. Y tened presente que el mundo de
hoy presenta muchas opciones para
no tener que depender de nadie ni
siquiera de Estados Unidos. México es
una nación soberana y libre,
ninguno de vuestros políticos debería
olvidarlo nunca. Bueno amigos, espero que
este vídeo os haya resultado
interesante, si ha sido así y queréis
que hablemos más de México dadle al
botón de la like y suscribiros al canal
para estar atentos a nuestros vídeos. Por
cierto si quiere saber por qué China
está haciéndose con Latinoamérica
haced click aquí. ¡Un saludo y hasta la
próxima!